[inaudible]
have you ever heard this phrase?
Yes.
Sounds pretty good,
right?
I mean,
it's quite a proclamation,
a call to an epic objective and appeal
to the people's pride towards
resistance.
But truth is though,
that over the years,
this slogan has become one of the
chance,
the essential slogans of every protest,
especially in Latin America and
especially in protests and
demonstrations of Marxist Leninist,
Maoist and socialist movements of all
kinds.
Going back,
one thing [inaudible] what about the get
that'll regarding battle,
because there aren't the 20th century,
these types of chance,
proclamations and slogans supported a
huge number of groups and protest
movements throughout Latin America.
This happened to such an extent that in
many cases,
these epicondyle brave slogans,
they had a far more terrible phenomenon
of phenomenon that it became one of the
most remarkable characteristics of the
entire region,
the gorillas,
[inaudible] [inaudible].
What does the gorilla phenomenon consist
of and why did it emerge?
I mean,
how could gorillas have such an impact
and so much power in,
well,
what's their situation like today?
What are we going around?
So all of those questions,
and there's a video,
but first a bit of history
come,
hey,
the spark that ignited the flame is the
1960s the gorilla phenomenon is about to
begin the Cuban revolution.
It's just happens.
And folks,
we really can't talk about guerrillas in
Latin America without us taking Cuba's
roll into account.
Yep.
You heard that right?
The Cuban revolution was a great source
of inspiration for all kinds of anti
imperialist,
revolutionary and communist movements.
Not only that,
but over the years,
Cuba say became the number one promoter
of guerrilla groups in the entire
region.
Yeah.
We could say that Cuba,
it was quite a powerful station,
that center.
The fact is that the myth of the Cuban
Revolution was the main reason that
thousands of young idealists,
in many cases with good intentions helps
10 last in America into a Hornet's nest.
How could they resist the exploits of
the Great Command of Fidel Castro,
the leader of that supposedly managed to
get the revolution running with just 82
people.
If he could do it,
why could ends others?
I mean,
get the rifle boys.
Let's crack on.
Well,
many of these young people,
they clearly felt this quite fervently.
You see,
the truth is that the revolution managed
to triumph to a great extent,
is precisely because of the excessive
violence and repression of the Cuban
dictator,
full henslow,
Battista.
These were accesses that got a good part
of the army,
including several officers who align
with Castro.
Great.
And by the way,
did you know that unlike what's commonly
said to this heroic revolution,
it didn't really have a clear
ideological objective.
First,
in 1959 Fidel Castro,
he never tired of repeating again and
again to the Cuban people,
among others.
He wasn't a communist.
Fidel himself,
he said this,
I know you're worried about whether or
not were communists.
I want to make this clear.
We aren't communists.
I'm not a communist,
and neither is our movement.
You,
they'll Castro communities.
And in a future video,
we probably do need to talk about the
Cuban revolution.
So we'll do that at some point in the
future.
But folks,
many,
many members over the revolution,
they were communists.
However,
it wasn't until two years after the
revolutionary triumph in 1961 that Fidel
declared himself a Marxist Leninist and
proclaimed the socialist revolution.
Yeah.
We can ask ourselves two questions.
What change in these two years and why
is this important?
Well,
listen up
operation center
speak their Washington politicians never
believed Fidel Castro statements denying
communism.
In fact,
they saw this new regime in Havana is a
danger during the cold war.
That's how the disastrous Bay of Pigs
invasion attempt merged.
At the same time,
this was quite clear to the Soviet Union
leaders.
Cuba meant an incredible opportunity and
mainly for three reasons.
Okay.
First,
by allying with Cuba,
they'd gain a very advantages
geographical position to the United
States.
They would have a friendly territory and
a military base just a few kilometers
from the American maintenance.
Second day,
socialist Cuba would mean a new
satellite stage.
Thus reinforcing that position in
international politics and third,
Cuba.
It could become the operations center to
spread communism in the u s is so called
back yard.
That's Latin American.
Gotcha.
That way folks,
that Soviet Union's chances of winning
the Cold War,
they absolutely grew stronger and you
know what has we usually say here at
visual politic so that we said and say
it was done.
The regime then led by Nikita Khrushchev
concentrated on consolidating its
relations with the new Castro I'd Cuba,
and it was quite a strong focus from
that very moment,
Cuba became a center for training,
financing,
and supplying equipment and weapons for
their revolutionary movements throughout
the continents.
That's how Havana became the biggest
gorilla uprising promoter in Latin
America.
The duty of every revolutionary is to
make the revolution.
The second declaration of Havana,
February 4th,
1962 the idea development by El Che was
that a small group of activists could
initiate a typical guerrilla war actions
and blew up existing institutions to
spread the flames of the socialist.
And not just that,
they also promoted a new strategy known
as cultural Marxism.
This,
by the way,
it's still seen in many places.
So what exactly does this strategy
consistent of?
Basically it's using education and
culture app to help communist and
revolutionary ideologies infiltrates
society to this ends.
The Cuban regime supported the creation
of songs,
poems,
university writings into literary works
of all kinds with a common
characteristic.
All of them were steeped in
revolutionary ideology and among other
things,
extolled the gorilla figure.
Take Education and culture,
and the rest.
We'll add on Antonio Gramsci.
Now,
if you want to know more about how
Havana supported some of the most famous
gorillas.
Well,
listen up
ties
the first operation,
it happens in Nicaragua.
Thanks to Moscow and Savannah's
technical and military and economic
support.
The Revolutionary Leader Carlos Fon
sacker amador,
promoted the creation and organization
of the Sandinista at National Liberation
Front in 1961 if you've heard of it,
that's probably because it's Daniel
Ortega's movements.
Who's the current tyrons presidents of
Nicaragua about which we've already
spoken in several videos here are visual
politic.
Yup.
Let's go back to it.
Yeah.
In 1969 at Carlos Fonseca moved to
Havana where he spent the next six years
from that he organized the Sandinista
Front.
In 1975 he returns to Nicaragua to solve
some leadership problems and unify the
gorilla group.
And although a year later,
this revolutionary leader was
assassinated in 1979 the Sandinista
friends,
they finally seized power.
Okay.
The gorilla trained and financed and
supported by Havana at triumphed,
the model it worked.
So why stop in 1980 a year after the
Sandinista fronts triumph,
the F M N,
l,
V,
Pharaoh,
Buddha,
Marty France,
fuck national liberation was founded in
El Salvador with Fidel Castro himself as
an intermediary.
What's more of this group?
It was founded in [inaudible] honor
itself.
Wow.
With the support of the Cuban regime,
along with that of the new Nicaraguan
government and Moscow,
of course,
the f m n l started it's armed fight
their training centers where the
occasion in Cuba and Nicaragua,
of course,
it was those same countries,
which provided them with weapons,
supplies,
equipment,
and anything else.
They need it.
No,
hold on for a moment.
As you can imagine,
the United States didn't just stand that
they weren't willing to give Havana
another victory,
so they decided to support the
Salvadoran government.
Their results.
12 years of fighting that cost more than
75,000 deaths,
thousands more missing,
and an economic.
Now we can begin to understand the
magnitude of the violence that has
destroyed so much of this region.
The fact is that on this occasion,
the gorillas,
they didn't achieve a revolution and
after the peace agreement of 1990 they
formed a political party.
Does any of this party governs El
Salvador runs?
Of course,
it hasn't hesitated to support Daniel
Ortega's Nicaraguan regime,
but don't think for a second that this
situation has happened solely in Central
America,
not at all the southern countries.
They also had that Shat South America
also underwent a wave of revolutionary
movements in facts throughout Latin
America.
More than a hundred hundred gorilla
groups caused enormous damage.
Almost all of them were encouraged and
supported by Cuba in one way or another.
That's certainly true for the most
famous gorilla groups.
FARC,
the April 19th movement in Colombia,
and it's the shining path in Peru,
Shining Path.
Activists have been trained in Cuba,
Czechoslovakia and the German Democratic
Republic.
Manuel who law,
former prime minster of Peru and
statements to the bias newspaper in 1983
all you surprise now that the peace
agreements between Fark and Juan Manuel
Santos is Colombian government will be
negotiated in.
Yeah.
Vonda.
Of course these huge groups,
true army is also had another
fundamental support points and that's
drug money.
Yup.
These groups ended up becoming drug
traffickers business from which they
obtained the enormous resources they
needed to continue the fight.
Awesome.
Don't forget that Cuba also went into
this business we told you about that.
Here are visual politic in a recent
video about Nahko politics in this
region of the wells.
Yes.
The Cuban government even associated
with Pablo Escobar himself and that's
when it all,
the last example of Cuban infiltration,
we all know was in Venezuela and we've
already seen how things are giving that.
Okay
folks,
Cuba's influence on Latin American
politics in the last 60 years has been
terrible.
Havana has played a major role in back
and guerrilla groups and regimes that
have done absolutely no good for Latin
America.
Yeah,
and I know nowadays some people still
view these groups with a certain
romanticism,
but that really isn't mistake beyond the
feets and the myths,
the real story,
unfortunately,
it's terrible,
but fortunately the gorillas are now at
the lowest point in decades and that at
least is good news.
By the way.
Many of the guerrilla groups,
they weren't just Havana's faults.
In many cases,
they were the fault if a terribly
extractive oligarchy that control to
their country with an interest in
nothing but maintaining that own
privileges.
This has also been one of the great
evils of the region.
So with this video,
we can own fleet now better understand
how so many guerrilla groups suddenly
emerged in Latin America and why
relations between Washington and Havana
have traditionally been so bad.
The story,
it goes far beyond the missile crisis.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends of the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine.
Also this,
it's possible because Patrion and our
patrons on that platform,
please do consider joining them in
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you next [inaudible]
aliens.